[Music]
okay Google defined modular modular
employing or involving a modular modules
as the basis of design or construction
define module module each of a set of
standardized parts or independent units
that can be used to construct a more
complex structure such as an item of
furniture or a building or a smartphone
thanks for watching now so the simplest
easiest to understand definition of
modular is something where all the parts
can be removed or replaced so if
something is completely modular all of
the parts even the necessary ones can be
removed or replaced if it's semi modular
then some of the parts can be removed
and replaced and if it's not modular
that all the parts are fixed so this for
example is not modular this is this is
not modular this is this is not modular
and this is and modular tech is usually
the best kind of tech because when you
can take out parts and replace them like
a graphics card in a computer that also
means that you can upgrade parts at any
time just one piece at a time at your
will which means you don't even have to
wait until something's broken if you
just decide you want a piece of
something to be better than it is now
you can buy the replacement upgrade it
and just make it happen so recently
we've been thinking of ways to make
things in tech that haven't been modular
in the past modular like smartphone and
we started getting really optimistic
about modular smartphones like just the
whole idea of being able to swap the
parts in and out at any time so let's
say your phone you really like your
phone but it's starting to get a little
bit slow instead of buying a whole new
smartphone to replace it you can just
buy a new CPU module swap out that and
your phone as good as new or let's say
you want to take better photos and some
new better optics are coming out you can
swap out a camera module and you're good
to go or let's say you're going on a
road trip this summer swap out a bigger
battery module a video about this exact
topic got about 20 million views or so
in a week it was called phone blocks
it's made of blocks detachable blocks
they are all connected to the base and
the base connects everything together so
this phone blocks was a crowdfunding
campaign that looked like it was going
to be an actually brand-new brilliant
awesome idea because it kind of was I
mean this was the first time people were
actually considering doing a fully
modular smartphone not just a removable
battery or not just expandable storage
but everything I mean look at the
screenshot this is from the actual video
and I mean it makes it look like you can
replace anything the audio jack the
gyroscope other sensors I mean I don't
know what's in a speed module maybe my
SOC but I can replace that too that
seems awesome and then we heard nothing
for a while like I mean we got the
occasional update like oh we're still
trying or whilst we're still working on
this but for the most part it just
stayed in concept form for a long time
now it's kind of disappointing but then
we got our hopes up again with project
ara which was a sort of a resurfaced
version of phonebloks
had a lot of the same looks from
phonebloks the modules that slide into a
base hot swappable upgradeable parts and
even a little bit of a better looking
design I would say but again this was
more than a year ago and it's still all
concept form we never got any phones to
play with just dummies of what the phone
would look like so a couple weeks ago at
Google i/o we got our project our update
which is great we actually got some
prototypes of working modular phones
which is awesome to see but these were a
far cry from the original concept as we
kind of expected these are more like
semi modular phones because now project
ara doesn't let you swap you know the
CPU the GPU the RAM heck even the
speakers and the screen are all fixed
you will be able to swap things like the
camera and the battery so naturally that
news is a bit disappointing to those of
us who are really waiting for that idea
but it's still exciting that we will see
a project ara
developer device by the end of this year
and then a consumer device that we can
buy starting next year of course this is
all dependent on Google getting all
these third-party manufacturers to
actually make a whole bunch of different
modules for us to choose from so there's
an actual reason for us to try
fast forward to today and we're still
kind of high on this idea of modular
smartphones and we've gotten devices
like this LG g5 g5 by itself is a pretty
good phone it's pretty decent it's not
my full review of it obviously but it's
a pretty good phone but its main selling
point is that it's modular kinda because
it has modules this would again fall
under the category of stemming modular
in fact the truth is the g5 is barely
modular like I would hesitate to even
use that word to describe it it has a
couple of attachable accessories but you
can't swap the memory or anything you
can't swap the cameras you can't swap
any sensors or ports is basically just
the battery so it's sort of like a rough
draft and I love LG for trying but this
is like 25% of a modular phone it could
have been way more awesome if there were
more third-party accessories like auras
planning to have and there are also
rumored plans for a Motorola modular
Moto X with pins on the back and
accessories that can attach later this
year that will also depend on how many
third-party manufacturers make these
accessories here's the thing though this
generation is first generation of
modular smartphones that we're getting
now is sort of like a rough draft of
those crazy ideas that we had a couple
years ago there's no new tech to make
these crazy new ideas happen since then
so what we're doing is using old tech
and sort of trying to morph it into sort
of a modular thing which is pretty crazy
and bold and daring but 99% of people
don't really care about a Lego like
build your own modular smartphone type
of thing and the last 1% who do also
want it to be pretty cheap both of you
think about it making the ideal
future-proof fully modular smartphone
for us now whatever company does that
would kind of be screwing themselves
over in a long run when they want to
introduce a new phone let's say next
year no one's going to want to buy it
because I'll just want to buy new
modules for their own instead actually
asked about this on Twitter and
someone's reply was all I care about is
the ability to swap out stock batteries
for i/o capacity ones and adding more
memory via SD cards when I need it so
number one smartphone manufacturers
already know that and they're kind of
willing to build that into certain
models as long as you pay a little extra
for it and number two is that really
modular
barely so the truly fully modular
smartphone could be the best thing that
happens to the smartphone market when it
does happen both for us consumers
because it's going to be awesome
for the environment so we don't have to
buy all these new phones all the time
and for geeks because it's just a dope
concept but it's a long way off fingers
crossed for project ara though thanks
for watching
I'll talk to you as the next one peace
[Music]